pilgrims continued to stream across the  bridge even after the Stampede while  others waited in a state of shock next  to the bodies local media say up to half  a million people came to the remote  temple for the ten-day religious  festival it's not clear what triggered  the panic at a nearby hospital one  pilgrim blamed the police people were  leaving from both the exits after  worshipping the goddess suddenly police  arrived they began shouting that the  bridge had broken and they also charged  the devotees with batons but police tell  another story blaming pilgrims who were  tired of waiting on the crowded bridge  some people spread a rumor that the  bridge was falling their objective was  to reach the temple quickly they were  unable to go due to a massive crowd this  led to the Stampede police say the 500  meter long bridge is about three years  old and structurally sound all too often  religious events in India have been  marred by deadly stampedes